bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
kiosques que votre magazine culturel sur
50 en ville et ses environs tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 13
janvier
dimanche 10 janvier saint quentin en
yvelines accueilli l'écrivain à succès
planétaire anna torv téléchargée plus
d'un milliard de fois sur internet pour
sa saga after cette jeune américaine de
26 ans venait dédicacer son dernier
livre before sorti jeudi en france en
écho au festival d'angoulême
le réseau des médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines organise la bd dans
tous ses états du 13 au 30 janvier
julien omnes responsable de l'espace bd
de la médiathèque jacques brel de magny
les hameaux et en plateau pour nous en
parler
l' architecture moderne de saint quentin
en yvelines et sa mise en lumières
naturelles attirent les réalisateur pour
tournée film d'action et films d'auteur
à l'image de xavier senio et julien seri
nous recevront en plateau dans quelques
instants
l'équipe de xavier senio on commence
tout de suite avec un événement qui a
attiré les jeunes filles par centaines
et de par toute la france dimanche le
dernier 10 janvier à saint quentin en
yvelines
la séance de dédicaces dana todt pour sa
nouvelle saga before sorti jeudi en
france image de patrick jacques de
dixmude
elles sont jeunes voire très jeunes
passionnés par les histoires d'amour et
surtout elles sont venus par centaines
rencontré l'écrivain phénomène de l'ohio
anatole elle se trouvait dimanche 10
janvier au carrefour de saint quentin en
yvelines pour dédicacer sa nouvelle saga
before sorti jeudi en france ça fait un
an que j'attendais ça c'est beaucoup
d'émotions j'aimerais être écrivain
comme l est du coup c'était vraiment
important pour moi
il assure jusqu'au bout c'est vraiment
mon moment préféré ça me permet de
sentir l'intérêt que les gens me porte
beaucoup de personnes sont venues leur
présence est vraiment incroyable pour
moi
à seulement 26 ans anatole a déjà été
traduite en 34 langues pour sa
précédente saga after téléchargée plus
d'un milliard de fois sur wattpad la
plateforme communautaire de partage de
récit le secret de ce succès planétaire
une étudiante modèle un mauvais garçon
une histoire d'amour à laquelle on
s'identifie facilement
j'adorais son roman et que c'est ya tout
dedans il ya de l'amour il ya de
l'action il ya des trahisons et c'est
génial tout ce que j'aime et elle est
incroyable elle très proche de nous et
d'ailleurs j'ai on a l'impression
qu'elle nous comprend des seuils les
femmes disent qu'ils ml vous que même
qu'ils m'aiment et même cela leur donne
envie d'écrire mais la plupart du temps
ils aiment les livres donc ils lisent
plus après before and after a pour objet
d'écrire deux autres livres avec les
personnages de la série after de quoi
contenter ses nombreuses lectrices qui
pourront à nouveau intervenir dans
l'écriture des romans sur les
plateformes de partage en littérature
toujours aux gens jaggi écrivain et
arcisien vient de publier aux éditions
internet publibook son premier thriller
sommes-nous trop tard l'histoire d'un
homme plongé dans le coma victime d'un
accident de voiture qui finit par se
réveiller son savoir si tout ce qu'il a
entendu appartient au rêve à la réalité
une écriture nerveuse emprunté au cinéma
l'une de ses passions des chapitres
courts des phrases courtes des phrases
assez rapide ce qui a fait dire
effectivement que vont l'écriture était
empruntée au cinéma que je suis un très
grand fan de
de cinéma quand j'étais plus jeune c'est
encore jeune j'espère y aller jusqu'à
deux à trois heures par semaine donc
beaucoup d'action beaucoup de rapides
essayer de ne pas perdre de temps pas
trop trop description non plus et la
particularité c'est un j'ai eu un écho
d'une lectrice qui m'a dit on est en
train de lire un film il ya un travail
énorme ce n'est pas non plus parce qu'il
ya du travail mais il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de recherches
il ya eu un meilleur entourage pour mais
pour mes corrections et vous n'êtes pas
sans le savoir la quatrième édition du
festival d'angoulême approche à grands
pas ce serait du 28 au 31 janvier
prochain alors pour tous les passionnés
qui ne pourraient s'y rendre le réseau
des médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines organise la bd dans tous ses
états du 13 au 30 janvier prochains en
plateau avec nous julien omnes vous êtes
immédiate eckert et responsable de
l'espace bd de la médiathèque jacques
brel de magny les hameaux
bonsoir alors vous avez dû suivre un
petit peu la polémique autour justement
du festival d'angoulême cette année
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est compliqué c'était évitable
surtout en ce moment il ya de plus en
plus d'auteurs femmes
c'est assez étrange en fait c'est assez
l'étranger vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne chose quand même le la
multiplication des auteurs femmes il n'y
a pas de raison qui vous avez tout dit a
pas de raisons elles sont très visibles
sur les réseaux sociaux de plus en plus
avec des grands noms sommes donc oui
effectivement vous avez vous dit à
partir du moment où elles sont
compétentes
voilà le milieu doit s'ouvrir alors je
vais disais tout à l'heure julien omnes
vous est immédiate et ksm qu'est ce
qu'un mini médiathécaires un immédiate
et qui a bien historiquement le métier
c'est bibliothécaire ça fait bien 20 ans
maintenant qu'on parle de médiathécaires
on s'est ouvert aux différents médias
plus uniquement les livres dvd cd etc
li médiathécaires aujourd'hui c'est le
médiathécaires du 21e siècle c'est à
dire qu'on est capable de faire des
collections en vrai en dur mais aussi
sur internet tout simplement
dématérialisée d'accord donc vous êtes
immédiate et caire mais avec une
spécialité ce set de la bd que vous
mettez en place que vous organisez
c'est ça la médiathèque jacques brel de
magny les hameaux e jacques brel oui et
puis aussi avec le réseau avec des
collègues on est un groupe de 12 15
personnes a travaillé très régulièrement
soit toutes les six semaines et il ya
une vraie grosse émulation notamment au
niveau des suivis des dix taureaux des
suivis des bandes dessinées aussi au
niveau éditorial beaucoup beaucoup de
choses et c'est un groupe qui marche
très très bien et qui contribuent à
faire avancer vraiment ce se font avec
beaucoup d enthousiasme parce que bd 9e
art c'est un art qui attire de plus en
plus en fait les lecteurs et on peut
faire passer différents messages
notamment des messages historiques on
avait fait tout un sujet là dessus donc
justement du 13 au 30 janvier la bd dans
tous ses états ce serait sur l'ensemble
des réseaux des médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines il y aura différents
ateliers des expositions expliqué ont
alors l'idée depuis plusieurs années
maintenant à saint quentin c'est
effectivement sur cette période de
janvier de proposer à nos adhérents tout
un tas d'animations dans les différents
sites du réseau
alors ça peut être des conférences à peu
des expositions ça peut être des auteurs
qui viennent partager leur leur comment
leur passion notamment par des ateliers
alors on a des ateliers manga on a des
ateliers comics on a aussi cette année
notamment chez moi nous y sept marins
caricaturiste qui va venir pour revenir
sur la bd humour qui est généralement un
peu mis de côté tout un tas de choses
alors justement parmi ses nombreux
événements vous pouvez également
retrouver l'exposition alfred présentée
actuellement au conservatoire des arts
de montigny le bretonneux jusqu'au 30
janvier prochain fauve d'or au dernier
festival d'angoulême 2013 alfred est un
auteur de bande dessinée
totalement autodidacte artiste complet
il pratique la bande dessinée
l'illustration l'adaptation du roman
pochettes de disques et dessins
satiriques en utilisant une large
palette de matériel pastel encre crayon
de couleurs acryliques mais encore
aquarelles cette expo elle répond à une
attente vraiment particulière c'est à
dire que depuis maintenant un an et demi
là le choix des des artistes a été
confiée un petit groupe de professeurs
du conservatoire
il ya vraiment cette volonté de
présenter une exposition de toutes les
disciplines qu'on va pouvoir enseigner
on a eu à peu près 600 élèves en bande
dessinée depuis ces vingt dernières
années on avait vraiment à coeur de
présenter un travail de grande qualité
donc ça je pense que alors julien omnes
parmi justement ce toute cette diversité
d'événements il ya également des
événements scolaire et vous vouliez nous
parler d'une manifestation en
particulier
oui on travaille cette année avec quatre
équipements scolaires sur saint quentin
en yvelines
l'idée étant de faire venir chez eux un
auteur nicolas des rues qu'un jeune
auteur qui science qui est bourré de
talent qui d'ailleurs va être chez nous
au canal pendant cette période est donc
on l'emmène avec nous dans les classes
on fait travailler les enfants sur des
bandes dessinées c'est un projet qui est
assez lourd qui est très pédagogique et
qui j'en suis persuadé va continuer à
grandir et à apporter beaucoup de choses
aux enfants
je n'ai omnes merci d'avoir été avec
nous au plateau aujourd'hui et je
rappelle que la bête était dans tous ses
états c'est organisé sur l'ensemble du
réseau des médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines ce sera c'est jusqu'au 30 31
pardon même janvier prochain toutes les
informations sur le site qui s'affiche à
l'écran théâtre maintenant pierrot
lunaire de schoenberg ne cesse de
fasciner susciter la créativité des
artistes
cette oeuvre musicale de 10 912 prend
cette fois vie au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à l'aide d'un
ensemble de marionnettes japonaise la
première représentation de ce spectacle
de création sera samedi 16 janvier dans
une maison de thé au japon pierrot est
amoureux de colombine label geisha mais
par crainte du terrible cassandre ils ne
peuvent s'aimer qu'en cachette
pierrot lunaire de schoenberg est une
oeuvre musicale composée en 1912 elle
est revisité au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines samedi 16
janvier
l'âme du spectacle essentiellement est
tout d'abord c'est la musique celle de
schoenberg arnold schönberg pierrot
lunaire une oeuvre fabuleuse écrite en
1912 et qui garde encore tout son
mystère toute sa modernité
on n'a pas fini de l'explorer on va dire
emotionnellement artistiquement dans son
exécution
la nouveauté c'est la dramaturgie c'est
l'ajout d'une histoire et de sa
représentation par des marionnettes de
type boudera coup c'est à dire des
marionnettes japonaise dans une
scénographie days pour donner forme
vivante à cette oeuvre 4 marionnettes
japonaise du théâtre baudrac ou
s'animeront au premier plan guide et
chacune par trois marionnettistes un
travail de coordination pour arriver à
donner deux concerts un même souffle à
la marionnette a les qualités pour être
de bons marionnettiste c'est avant tout
je pense d'être comédien c'est à dire de
savoir cerner un personnage c'est à dire
de pouvoir rentrer voir tout ce que le
personnage peut faire en réponse à ses
partenaires aussi d'être d'avoir un
excellent entraînement physique pour
lorsqu'on est trois sur une manne
marionnettes avoir la même respiration
et transmettre la même impression
émotions de concert sur un même corps
qu'on anime au deuxième plan les
musiciens et la chanteuse se servent de
fil directeur à la narration du comte de
pierrot formé par un ensemble de 21
points également
l'instrumentation est singulière avec
l'utilisation du spray shégués zinc le
ce prêche à gaza c'est donc
effectivement une façon de déclamer le
texte et un peu chantée mais pas tout à
fait à schönberg avait ainsi inscrit des
hauteurs de notes ne s'agit surtout pas
de le chanter initialement c'était une
commande pour une grande amie
une certaine madame zemin qui avait
l'habitude de réciter des poèmes
accompagnés par un piano donc schönberg
a accédé à sa demande et elle d'en créer
cette longue histoire avec cette
difficulté
effectivement dix crèches kaisin où il
faut dire sans chanter et chanter sans
dire un spectacle de création qui
conjugue expressionnisme allemand et
poésie japonaise à découvrir pour sa
première au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le samedi 16
janvier et place maintenant au septième
art en plateau avec moi xavier senio
auteur réalisateur et professeur de
français bonsoir
jérémy chauveau vous êtes acteur et
vincent gros vous êtes con scénaristes
dont son rebond sera alors bonsoir à
tous les trois javier senio vous
réalisez enfin vous vous avez récupéré
les fonds les faits ni les financements
privés pour réaliser votre deuxième long
métrage qui s'appelle nemesis c'est un
thriller c'est votre premier thriller
axée autour de questionnements autour du
monde de la justice c'est cela que vous
pourriez nous expliquer un petit peu
davantage ce lourd projet qui vous tient
tant à coeur
alors ben en fait après avoir fait mon
premier film il ya trois ans vincenzo
guzzo d'ailleurs
qui était très amateur le 1er mai on a
essayé de faire vraiment le mieux
possible et du coup ça m'a permis
d'avoir plus de 2 dead de financement de
personnes qui ont rejoint mon deuxième
projet et j'ai écrit un roman fins en
train d'écrire que sa peine le masi et
qu'effectivement traite de la question
de la justice a un peu un policier
thriller policier et je me suis dit que
ça ferait un film après film fin avec
pas mal d'ingrédients du suspense de
l'action d'attention de la réflexion etc
et je me suis dit ça pourrait être super
se lancer dedans et puis là ça fait un
an et demi qu'on est dessus et ça se
passe plutôt bien pour l'instant
alors vincent justement est-ce que le
scénario s'inspire du contexte social
oui exactement puisque justement
aujourd'hui justement notre époque où
la justice on se pose des questions sur
la justice est elle bien fait et elle
juste là on a un personnage dans notre
histoire qui justement se pose ces
questions là et se pose en acteur de
cette justice en essayant de faire
justice lui même est justement là il se
rend compte que c'est pas si simple que
ça je lui disais vous avez dû en fait
faire appel aux donations des généreuses
personnes et faire appel à des
financements privés
parce que de nos jours les cinémas une
production c'est compliqué ah oui c'est
pas pour faire un film fou quand même
pas mal de moyens de fond de matériel
faut pouvoir réserver des lieux et c'est
donc au oui c'est assez compliqué on a
invalidé notre première on a fait un
dossier de subvention participative pas
internet donc là il a été validé on a
réussi à peut-être un objectif on a
obtenu trois mille quatre cents et
quelques en deux mois non c'est super et
là on va essayer de viser d'autres types
de subventions pour compléter le but
c'est d'arriver à 12000 ses navets 12000
on préfère vraiment tout ce que je
voudrais c'est top
donc là ce financement ça couvre à la
fois la pré production à la fois le
matériel et ce tour le tournage à la
rémunération des acteurs commerciaux des
acteurs que c'est à ce qui est super
c'est qu'il a vraiment pas mal de
personnes sont mobilisées pour mon
projet à la fois des amateurs mais aussi
des professionnels et tous pour
l'instant travaillent bénévolement et
après on va dans un deuxième temps en
fonction de l'impact du film comme en
face à leur tour qui pourrait avoir pour
toute équipe jérémy vous êtes acteur
pour ce film donc c'est un engagement
humain un engagement artistique qui vous
a donné envie de participer au projet
ouais c'est surtout surtout humains en
fait on en avait fait le premier film
ensemble et on s'était éclatées
donc oui c'est pour ça que j'ai accepté
fin mai une chose que j'ai passé les
castings du coup qu'il a accepté de
notre angle mais ouais
puis artistique quoi c'est quand même
sympa de faire un film quand elle me dit
à l'âge que j'ai c'est cool de pouvoir
participer à un projet comme ça quoi
alors au delà d'être d'être agréable
pour l'esprit collectif parce que dans
le scénario est ce que dans l'écriture y
avait quelque chose auquel vous étiez
particulièrement sensible bah ouais je
trouve que c'est vraiment sympa et déjà
comme idée le film le scénario
le pivot des minimes touche pas
particulièrement c'est vraiment voilà je
pense que c'est le fait déjà tu de
regret dans ce truc là je pense qu'il
m'a rien proposé
pas n'importe quel film est donc utile
je serai accepté ouais clairement
clairement à ses fins plaisir et puis en
plus soit le film me plaît je trouve
qu'il fait vraiment sympa et je trouve
que ça change un peu de ce qu'on voit
tous les jours il ya un petit peu plus
de réflexion ça va un peu plus loin que
justin simply scié ou un thriller face à
atlante tout ça et c'est ça qui m'a plus
vraiment au delà de l'intrigué vieillard
il ya une forme de critique une forme de
dénonciation qui est mise en lumière
alors moi parce que je suis aussi
romancier à côté et ça que tout mes fans
d'histoire roman ou films j'aime
beaucoup effectivement qui est de
l'action au suspense de la tension c'est
tenir le spectateur houleux
les lecteurs en haleine etc mais j'aime
bien que ce soit pas gratuit en fait
même quand il ya de l'action que la
violence est star je veux pas qu'ils
soient gratuits derrière il ya souvent
une réflexion et c'est vrai que dans les
oasis ya quand même beaucoup de scènes
qui ont été écrites à l'image de quelque
chose à l'image de quelque chose qui
s'est passé en france et d'image de
d'une certaine justice etc
derrière quand même un message sur pas
mal de scènes etc oui un message pour
les spectacles ou non aller plus loin
que la simple lecture du film pour aller
plus loin effectivement dans la lecture
alors vous avez vous êtes ville provient
vous avez également décidé avec votre
équipe de tourner le film sur saint
quentin en yvelines
alors il y aura trappe tu auras plaisir
y aura de villepreux pourquoi ce lieu
tournage vincent à vrai dire c'est parce
que d'abord avant tout c'est un
environnement qui convient tout le monde
étant donné qu'on est tous du coin en
fait à la base et puis on a fait des
repérages dans dans le coin en fait avec
des lieux qui nous conviennent pour
tourner alors après on dit pas que on va
tourner toutes les scènes dans le coin
et peut-être des salons etc c'est la
torah certaines scènes à la principale
au niveau de l' architecture c'est un
territoire qui est intéressant bah tout
à fait oui parce qu'il ya un peu tout
est dans le coin on la forêt on a de la
ville mme que tout ce qu'on voudrait
avoir quoi alors je vais vous présenter
également un autre réalisateur julien
série qui lui aussi a opté pour son
dernier film night phare justement qui a
choisi saint quentin en yvelines comme
territoire on le regarde tout de suite
les temps de parler cinéma à présent
nous ressemble ce soir en plateau julien
seri bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à main alors vous êtes
le fondateur de la société d'agro film
vous avez en grande partie est écrit et
réalisé yamakasi les fils du vent ou
encore scorpions avaient clovis
cornillac vous êtes ici pour nous parler
de votre fils knight phare qui est
sortie en avant première hier
alors si je résume l'histoire c'est
l'histoire de deux amis qui rentrent en
taxi de paris en soi et décide de faire
un taxi basket donc de ne pas payer la
course mais le chauffeur lui va les
poursuivre et pas forcément pour
l'argent on en parle tout de suite après
cet extrait
yoris ok i'm gonna give you up as they
come on girl is it on my mind
là c'est très bien monsieur va descendre
la loi merci pour l'info
mais regardez mon grand père flynn et
pékin aux chez césar ou non non
non je tenterai pas me casser les prix
pour cinq ans malgré trois autres car ça
arrivait de mecs l'asie dégage dans les
statuts au cul leva bien cherché
alors julien serré nous l'avons vu
c'est un film d'action mais c'est aussi
un peu un film d'auteur il a été tourné
en seulement quelques semaines à saint
quentin en yvelines
on a choisi saint quentin en fait paul
mignot l'un des coproducteurs a grandi
ici et sa maman vit encore ici chantal
mignot est donc un soir paul me dis mais
qu'est ce que tu me racontes du film
sochaux mène à saint quentin
donc on est venus en repérage une nuit
et j'ai trouvé la ville assez incroyable
visuellement très très riche avec des
décors déjà mis en lumière c'est
vraiment votre fan base un peu si on
peut dire est qu'elles participent et
voilà au film peu mais vraiment il ya
des gens à d autres peut-être sept
trotteurs du monde du cinéma qui choisit
bien voilà on s'implique parce qu'on
veut que julien seri continuer à faire
des films
alors c'est vrai que j'ai ma fanbase
entre guillemets qui était vraiment
présente mais c'est vrai que j'ai aussi
reçu l'aide de grands metteurs en scène
comme jean françois richet me mathieu
kassovitz jan kounen bruno aveillan des
avis et j'en serai de cabaye et florent
emilio siri et plein d'autres frais de
telli et plein d'autres qui m'ont tous
soutenus dans la démarche dans cette
démarche de cinéma en fait ils m'ont dit
c'est la première fois je pense que
c'est assez historique que autant de
metteur en scène deux entre guillemets
meilleur que moi meilleur qu'un metteur
en scène viennent le soutenir pour faire
son film et même certains ont même mis
de l'argent dans le film alors d'y amel
boubekeur vient de nous rejoindre en
plateau ils étaient bloqués dans les
transports djamel boubekeur bonsoir vous
êtes acteur dans le futur film nemesis
et vous allez interpréter le rôle d'un
petit voyou surnommé le requin
comment est ce que vous allez vous
préparer justement à ce rôle comme
travail qu'est ce que vous allez faire
je suis moi même comédien va coûter donc
c'est surtout pas de l'apprentissage
du texte le jeu de rôle l'expo tout ce
qui est expression ce qui est très
important pour tous les comédiens
comment est ce que vous faites pour vous
imprégner du rôle tout simplement
bah moi j'ai déjà une gêne j'ai déjà une
formation théâtrale assez poussées sur
paris pendant plusieurs années et c'est
ça qui m'a permis d'apprendre le métier
j'ai notamment fait beaucoup j'ai
notamment fait une master class il ya
deux ans mais c'est vrai que mon
exposition recul hier pour vraiment
s'inspirer de l'esprit d'un rôle là par
exemple c'est le rôle d'un voyou est ce
que il ya des techniques pour se plonger
vraiment dans le rôle ou pas drôle d'un
voyou on arrive je vois que certains
problèmes
qu'est ce qu'il ya tout de suite il faut
il faut tout de suite rentré dans le
dans le vif du sujet est vraiment jouer
l'expression à fond pour être le plus
crédible devant une caméra
c'est ce qu'ils font c'est ce qu'ils
font les comme on dira c'est ce qu'on
vous allez voir un film au cinéma
c'est ce qu'ils font les acteurs qui
vous font pleurer qui vont font rire
c'est qu'ils arrivent à sortir des
émotions c'est avec des fois c'est assez
difficile mais c'est la qualité qu'ils
ont de faire sortir des émotions comme
certains films qu'on a vu je sais pas ce
qui me vient à l'esprit comme
intouchable ou quoi que ce soit tous les
mecs avaient vraiment à sortir alors
qu'ils apprennent que du texte
tout est créé à l'avance il improvise
rien du tout c'est que l'uteq mais
arrive à sortir une émotion et c'est
beaucoup de travail
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup de travail
plus beaucoup de travail c'est plus que
que ce qu'on croit alors beaucoup de
travail c'est ce qui attend les acteurs
c'est également ce qui vous attend tous
les deux justement les futurs projets la
prochaine étape de nemesis en quelques
mois avant le tournage compte justement
pour que chaque acteur c'est un prenne
vraiment dû de la personnage je compte
les voix en amont plusieurs fois pour
qu'on travaille vraiment le personnage
avant de travailler les scènes en fait
la diction la manière de se comporter le
la gestuelle la manière de penser et
c'est je veux vraiment que les perdre et
les acteurs s'imprègne du personnage
mais je vais les voir un gm
deux voies samedi je dois samedi qui
arrive en vacances sans caméra sans fil
mais on va déjà commencer comment il
voit le personnage de jack mais parce
que je drague comme je le vois comment
comment il se comporte roma il parle et
c est donc tous les acteurs j'essaie de
voir enfin principaux jeux tous les voit
on va travailler en amont pendant un ou
deux mois avant le tournage en fait
voilà donc ça c'est pour la partie
artistique et puis voilà partis plus
administrative on va continuer à
chercher des fonds pour le film très
bien je crois que le message est passé
c'est un film qui normalement si tout se
passe bien sortir en 2017 on sale on
espère je vous le souhaite
xavier signaux djamel boubekeur jérémy
chauveau et vincent gros merci à vous
quatre d'avoir été en plateau et bonne
chance alors merci pour ce futur projet
nemesis qui sortira si tout va bien en
selle en 2017
on poursuit notre rubrique cinéma avec
vos réactions sur les nouveautés à la
fiche de cette semaine au micro de fanny
bourdillon ça m'a beaucoup plu comme
fils parce que c'est un sujet qui était
très tabou à l'époque début des années
heureusement les choses ont changé et
mais je pense pas que c'est un film pour
tout le monde
très émouvant ça c'est un film très très
beau et on se demande
bon c'était l'époque c'était comme ça
mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont raté
leur vie parce que il y avait des
interdits et voilà il retrace vraiment
le début de rocky balboa soit le 2 ou 3
4 il ya vraiment c'est vachement entre
l'acteur principal et rookie en question
c'est bien filmé en fait c'est beaucoup
de plans séquences qui sont super
intéressant dans les scènes de boxe et
et c'est super intensive en fait on est
scotché pendant tout chez nous bah y'a
des moments de franche rigolade est
depuis passée
c'est assez dur aussi
de voir la dureté de ce milieu même si
c'est une satire elle a de l'espace noir
et des clayes-sous-bois qui vous donne
son coup de coeur cette semaine notre
coup de coeur et le film au delà des
montagnes
réalisé par jason qui chine fin 99 tao
une jeune fille de fenyang est courtisé
par ses deux amis d'enfance
zong elian dit zinc propriétaires de
stations-service se destine à un avenir
prometteur tandis que lyon qui travaille
dans une mine à charbon le coeur entre
les deux hommes
tao va devoir faire un choix qui
scellera le reste de sa vie et celle de
son futur fils dollars de l'histoire des
sentiments forts le temps qui passe et
des personnages qui vieillissent le
réalisateur entraîne le spectateur dans
les mailles de sa toile d'araignée de
mètres de cinéma mais le plus surprenant
face à son cinéma c'est qu'ils ne nous
explique jamais on est happé dans son
monde de fiction le spectateur et
prouvera le plaisir de ce décès emporté
dans un drame profondément humain avec
ce film retenu en compétition lors du
dernier festival de cannes le
réalisateur signe un grand mélodrame
d'une ampleur sidérante qui bouleverse
le regard et le coeur jason qui cinéaste
de la mémoire et de l'oubli livre une
oeuvre majeure le film emmène le
spectateur vers des signes d'émotion
au delà des montagnes est proposé cette
semaine en version originale et est à
découvrir à l'espace philippe noiret
jeu et c'est déjà la fin du kiosque
émission à voir et à revoir sur notre
site internet
très bonne soirée à tous